[Music]
wow
hello there fortnite is about to unveil
an entire civilization underneath our
feet and to be fully prepared it's time
to recap all the story events of chapter
4 season 2 Mega I'm Adam Mario here's my
Creator code now sit your butt down for
10 minutes and let's do this
without warning buildings began to fall
from the sky and constructed a mega City
filled with new characters to meet in
fact wait there we need to go further
back to explain this phenomenon
the chapter began with Paradigm and the
Loopers helping the zero point create a
new world to reside in right away
something different this chapter we had
up-to-date modern parts of land smashed
together next to events from the past We
Were Somehow able to see an early
version of the imagined order and how
the original kinetic ore was found to
form the reality Bridge the very same
reality Bridge we already destroyed in
the future which was also in the past it
became apparent that we are rewriting
history right now chapter 4 saw the
introduction of stellen the oath-bound
rift Warden who was tasked with creating
a rift gate to travel between realities
we assisted in his efforts building a
friendship along the way and with all
friendships come secrets to be spilled
he watches us with dark purpose Stalin
is tormented by visions of a shapeless
man who controls him through fear he is
the one who demands the rift gate in the
final moments of the season the floating
butthole was turned on yet someone had
tampered with the coordinates and we
don't know who but there are two main
culprits either Amy did it as she
hijacked the rift gate in search of the
missing members of the seven or it was
Evie who didn't react at all as a black
hole formed in the sky overhead and now
we're back to where we started the
season
[Music]
from the sky and constructed a mega City
filled with new characters season 2
brought his new pois new story beats and
potentially the greatest movement-based
weapon in fortnite history damn I love
that sword and as I'm recording this
it's been vaulted yay epic games anyway
it turns out this new world is the home
of Eevee and the peace Syndicate which
is either the greatest coincident we've
ever seen or we can confirm that Evie
was the person who wrecked the rift gate
to bring Mega City her home reality to
this island after completing a harmless
hacking based Arc game Evie introduces
herself I'm Evie I work with the peace
Syndicate and I've been working off for
the adventure you're looking for you can
see that big beautiful city on your map
that's my hometown and it's in serious
trouble Evie is a high-ranking member of
the peace Syndicate one of many factions
in this new version of the island that
are on the brink of War someone is
trying to start a war between the
syndicates they know that without Unity
this city will fall apart we are
recruited by the peace indicate by
Thunder himself a reptile entrepreneur
Who dabbles as a chef too
I'm a restaurateur entrepreneur party
lizard and well-loved Men about town the
premise is very simple reunite the clans
of the world and find the person
responsible for all this sudden sabotage
and speaking of sabotage the peace
Syndicate have been targeted a digital
attack has corrupted valuable data
including files on the last reality
while searching the corrupted files we
meet triac knocks a mysterious secret
NPC who could be found by peace
Syndicate PC terminals All Season the
very same ones that were hacked hmm more
on him soon
[Music]
four weeks later the peace indicate
finally got back in touch using the
weird arcade machine Tech we are tasked
with reuniting two Clans with a deep
rivalry the river guard and the fox Clan
the river guard are an ancient clan that
holds a mantra of water to flow like
water and to cut like ice whereas the
fox Clan have been around in the
fortnite story for Years first revealed
in chapter one their skills seem to be
more stealth and Technology based there
is little chance of peace between these
two groups yet one person could change
that stray a spec ops character who
switched from the river guard and joined
their Rivals the fox Clan and wait
there's more his sister is the leader of
the river guard if we can convince those
two siblings to sit down and talk we
could achieve peace the river guard
demands skill with a blade to get their
attention
whereas the fox Clan need to be seen our
survival abilities to give us respect
after securing a place for the
hate-filled Clans to meet up thunder
man ice meal and suddenly they are no
longer enemies really it was that simple
the fox Clan and River guard shake hands
and peace is fulfilled three Clans are
now United who's next
week five arrived and it was like the
Golden Age of fortnite again map changes
and hints to the Future arrived not only
did the attack on Titan Crossover begin
but mysterious cracks appeared in the
ground beneath our feet then earthquakes
began to grow in number many believe
this was due to the zero point and
ripples of other realities seeping out
of that sphere impacting the map two
monoliths appeared this week we had one
on the island from day one of the season
yet now three stand completely
unbreakable one is in the snow biome one
is in the new Mega City biome and one is
in the oathbound biome by The Citadel
something is going to happen with these
things to compound all these changes a
new NPC could be found randomly at one
of the three monoliths serenade a siren
who looks to be part of the Herald's
Chrome and according to her introduction
video a power to bend reality nobody
knew at this point if she was
trustworthy or another Minion of the
last reality the only thing revealed
officially is her Affinity to water just
like the river guards what could that
represent I guess we find out next
season
[Music]
week six arrived and two more NPCs
secretly arrived on the island and
stayed in hiding Dahlia and sticks
hanging out all alone in cabins away
from major pois almost like they were
hiding it would be another three weeks
before we learned more about them
because right now the peace syndicates
are once again in our DMS asking for
help this time The Luminaries need
assistance the mystery Saboteur has
stolen valuable weapon Tech and we are
called in to recover the stolen weapons
and grab those electronic parts we saw
this out in double quick time and now
mystica the leader of the luminaries now
stands by our side with the peace
Syndicate The Luminaries are the Nerds
of the island who immediately use their
Superior brain capacity to find The
Saboteur and it's yet another clan
called the Unseen finally we are getting
answers
but before the story can continue week 8
drops our annual Star Wars Shenanigans
once again it was quite fun
we jump forward to week nine of the
season the peace Syndicate need our help
yet again it's time to put a stop to the
unseen's meddling but getting close
enough to them is difficult luckily
those luminaries have tech for us a
disguise that turns us into a
human-sized banana with sneaking skills
we make it into the unseen's
headquarters and secretly meet high wire
the de facto leader of the Unseen and
rezo her number two the Unseen are
described as unpredictable and therefore
nobody at all trusts them but
surprisingly by sneaking up Behind Enemy
Lines and talking to them face to face
we reveal a different story they are not
responsible for the sabotage but one of
their agents has gone Rogue now working
side by side with the Unseen we destroy
the tech allowing The Saboteur to gather
information on us all and then flip the
signal to find them almost 10 weeks of
looking for The Syndicate Saboteur and
it appears to be none other than Dahlia
and her partner in crime Styx who are
hiding on the island for weeks but who
are they working with well that leads us
back to this chap triac knocks the
original secret NPC right now we still
don't know much about this guy did he
get here through the rift gate before it
was destroyed is he a soldier of the
Lost reality is he manipulating Dahlia
and sticks to get the information he
needs as always fortnite leaves us with
more questions than answers meaning
season 3 is going to be a key season for
the lore
the final few updates of the season have
seen the cracks in the ground grow into
gigantic holes changing the landscape of
the island campsites have now popped up
and excavation squads have settled in
the wild season will be on as soon and
we are all but certain the cracks on the
ground outline the new POI coming next
season all thanks to that teaser trailer
enjoy your last few days on the island
because soon it will change forever
fortnite chapter 4 has already given us
countless incomplete storylines like
where is Jonesy what happened to Amy are
the seven still alive where are stellen
and the Ageless why is serenade here and
what is treac knocks real plan whatever
happens next is certain to reveal more
of the narrative it's got to be time for
answers I'll see you in season three
because now we are officially members of
the peace Syndicate I'm Adam you're
awesome I'll see you next time
[Music]